straight ahead on law and crime daily
an alternate juror in the derrick
chauvin trial is speaking out after the
verdict
dante wright is laid to rest one
family's quest for justice
as another family receives their day in
court
minneapolis thank you for not
letting the legacy of george floyd
end with that video and police in
columbus ohio
released the body cam video of the fatal
shooting of a 16 year old girl
plus one of the main suspects in a
shooting five years ago that left eight
members of a family dead
suddenly appears in court to change his
plea
and a judge hints at a trial date for
the accused parkland school shooter
nicholas cruz law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
brian ross in our studios in new york
along with co-host terry austin
and brian buckmeyer who's been on
assignment in minneapolis for the trial
of derrick chauvin
well now the first juror is speaking out
an alternate who was dismissed
just before deliberations began she
talked with cbs news
and says she too thought the former
officer was guilty
i just felt like the prosecution made a
really good
strong argument dr tobin was the one
that really did it for me he explained
everything i understood it
down to where he said this is the moment
that he lost his life
really got to me so who made an impact
with the defense
um good or bad made it just made an
impact
i don't think they had a good impact i
think he over promised in the beginning
and
didn't live up to what he said he was
going to do
brian buckmeyer does that surprise you
at all
not at all brian ross from day one even
opening statements and even a bit in
jury selection
we were saying that eric nelson was over
promising and underperforming
any good defense attorney will tell you
it's got to be the opposite
you've got to let the jury know that you
have no burden
and then from there build on top of the
case
i think his trial strategy was one that
the jury was not really
fond of clearly and terry certainly the
lawyers for the other three officers
are going to be looking at what she said
as they prepare to go to trial in august
brian you better believe they are paying
very close attention to
what she is saying and they will make
sure that they don't over promise
and undeliver and i think that they are
going to look for
experts who are going to be not only
knowledgeable
and be experienced but experts who like
dr tobin
can explain what is going on so that the
jury can understand it
so generally speaking i think king lang
and tao
are going to point at joven and
basically say look i was trying to save
the life i was trying to say turn him
and i was
nothing like derek tobin right terry
well even as people in minneapolis are
digesting the chauvin verdict
there was a funeral for dante wright
where reverend al
sharpton delivered a powerful eulogy for
the young man
killed by a police officer in a
minneapolis suburb
take your seat dante tell
george floyd who you are take your seat
dante shake hands with
phillip for philando castile take your
seat
because there's a special place in
heaven
for those that shed innocent blood now
all cops are not bad
i saw 10 get on the stand the other day
and testify against another policeman
that's why no change is here when you
see the blue wall of silence
tumble in a courtroom in minneapolis
when policemen understand that they are
committed to the oath
rather than to their colleague that's
when we know a breakthrough is coming
buckmeyer you were at the funeral for
dante right the blue wall of silence
tumbling reverend sharpton said
yeah so i was there had the pamphlet
honoring the life
of dante demetrious right that was the
theme there
but not only for for dante wright
kenneth walker was there
flannel castile's family was there the
floyd family was there
so many others who have joined this
fraternity not by their own volition
but just by happenstance and
circumstance they all came together to
support this family
understanding that the next year is
going to be a difficult one for them
all right brian and in that ohio case
the reverend referred to police have now
released
the body cam video of a columbus officer
shooting and killing
16-year-old makia bryant there are new
reports that she called 9-1-1
herself asking for protection from some
older girls
she can see on the video now with a
knife when the officer arrives on the
scene and a warning
this video may be difficult to watch
what's going on hey what's going on hey
hey hey
hey get down get down get down get down
she had a knife she just went at her
yeah
we have to ask ourselves
what information did the officer have
what did he see how much time did he
have
to assess the situation
and what would have happened if he had
taken no
action at all as chief woods has
indicated
a fully independent investigation is
being conducted by bci
the results will be public
and terry that was a tough video to
watch she was just 16 years old asking
for help apparently and she ends up dead
a tough case all around brian it is a
real
tragedy 16 years old is a very
tender age and when you have someone who
has a knife and they're lunging at
someone the police officer has to think
look i have to stop what is going on
it's a chaotic scene
and the chief of police even said that
when deadly force is being used
the police officer can respond with
deadly force
but you have to ask yourself could
something else
have been done to avoid this tragedy
and a jury at the end of the day may
very well be answering that very
question
and those videos from the police body
cams are so powerful aren't they
yes very much so no question you're
watching that and you're putting
yourself in the
place of the police officer and also
you're thinking about
all of the others who are there and what
their reaction might be
and you're thinking about what we've
already learned from the george floyd
case
how the police officers have to think
very quickly on their feet so
it's very good to have the body cam so
we can all see what exactly happened
yes indeed well still ahead on law and
crime daily
why an ohio man is now pleading guilty
to the murders of eight members of one
family
but first the expanding federal
investigation into practices of the
minneapolis police department
why some community activists are
skeptical
the impacts of the shogun case continue
to be felt a day after the guilty
verdict of derek shovin
attorney general merrick garland
announced a sweeping investigation
into the minneapolis police department
law and crime's antoinette levy takes a
look
at what that probe will entail anjanette
well brian the justice department has
conducted these investigations into
other police departments and typically
these types of investigations
lead to major reforms
this effort will be staffed by
experienced attorneys and other
personnel from the justice department's
civil rights division
and the u.s attorney's office for the
district of minnesota
the new civil investigation is separate
from
and independent of the federal criminal
investigation
into the death of george floyd a day
after derrick chauvin was found guilty
america's top law enforcement official
said prosecutors
will do a deep dive into the way
minneapolis pd
does business the investigation will
assess whether the minneapolis police
department
engages in a pattern or practice of
using excessive force
including during protests the
investigation will also assess
whether the mpd engages in
discriminatory conduct
the doj has conducted similar probes for
instance in ferguson missouri
following the death of michael brown
that investigation found
ferguson's police practices focused on
generating revenue
and reinforced racial bias it's going to
be very thorough
this is a civil investigation it's not a
grand jury
a criminal investigation this is not
going to take a week
two months it could take up to two years
minneapolis police chief madaria
arendando has pledged to cooperate
but local activists are concerned
because they say the doj was here
in 2016. the last time the doj was here
they came with all kinds of suggestions
and ideas
and the city formed work groups and a
bunch of us went to these work groups
and we worked with the city
and we tried to make new policy and all
of that went into final 13.
every bit of it was gone the hope is
that more will be done
this time if there is a pattern in
practice
especially in precinct 3 where it seems
like there's sort of a culture
and an attitude there you will see maybe
a consent decree
at the end of the day if not some type
of lawsuit
issuing an injunction against the police
department
as you heard merrick garland say the
civil rights division of the justice
department will lead this investigation
and on the criminal side we still don't
know whether or not the grand jury plans
to
return civil rights charges against the
four officers involved in george floyd's
death
brian and jeanette if the department of
justice finds major issues and they ask
for reforms and the minneapolis pd is
resistant then what happens
well the justice department has options
and one of the things that they can do
the prosecutors can do is file a civil
lawsuit
and that may lead to a judge actually
overseeing
and forcing the implementation of
possible changes
and in some cases they can actually
reach some sort of agreement
where they agree with the justice
department almost like a
federal monitor can be brought in to
make sure those changes are implemented
but they can sit down together and
hammer something out if a federal
federal judge gets involved if there is
resistance
we don't really expect that because the
police chief seems open to implementing
reforms
but we'll just have to wait and see how
it all turns out and terry austin
attorney
general garland is focused now on
minneapolis but how about other police
departments around the country aren't
they too
on the line absolutely brian i think
this is just the beginning we know for a
fact
that garland is really focused on making
sure that systemic racism
is not something that we see in the
criminal justice department
and he wants to make sure that other
cities and i think he'll be looking at
places like chicago and columbus where
in chicago we saw the shooting of
adam toledo and we saw obviously mckay
o'brien
in columbus so i think he's going to
look at all of these cities he's going
to do it
one at a time and he's going to make
sure that the
police departments in these cities are
doing their searches they're doing their
seizures
they're doing protests and they are
doing it without the bias of prejudice
racial prejudice and i think it's very
important because
this is the change that people want to
see not just
the individual accountability which
obviously was extremely
important and we saw some of that
obviously in the george ford derek
shoving case
but now they want to see on a federal
level that change is being
made on a federal level and i think he's
going to make sure that happens
and certainly seems to have much support
from the white house from the president
of the united states
all right well coming up on law and
crime daily the accused boulder
grocery store shooter now facing dozens
of new charges
plus an ohio family massacred five years
ago
hear why the main suspect in this deadly
custody battle
is now pleading guilty
breaking news now out of ohio in one of
the state's biggest and most troubling
murder investigations ever
antoinette levy's been covering the case
from the beginning as with us again with
a new development
and jeanette now brian eight members of
the rodent and gilly families were shot
in the head as they slept in pike county
ohio
back in april of 2016. but now one of
the four
family members jake wagner charged in
the killings
has admitted his involvement and the
involvement of his other three family
members
wagner had a daughter with hannah rhoden
who was one of the victims
prosecutors have claimed the murders
were carried out because the wagner
family wanted full custody of that
little girl
hannah her parents her brother two
cousins and two
uncles were all killed in april 2016 and
the wagners had
vehemently denied any involvement in the
crimes but now that has changed
jake wagner has agreed to testify
against his mother
his brother and his father in exchange
prosecutors have agreed to take the
death penalty off the table
and we're of course going to have much
more on this story
and some things from court on the next
edition of long crime daily
angelette what a case talk about a
family feud they understand the governor
actually showed up at the courthouse
yeah that's exactly right governor mike
dewine in ohio
was the attorney general when this case
happened back in 2016.
and so that was a small county where
this happened pike county ohio it's a
poor
county and the sheriff there who's now
in prison
for stealing money from the safe and
that it contained stolen it was
contained drug money seized and drug
deals he's now in prison we've covered
that before he called the ag and said
look this case is too big for us we want
you to lead it so
governor mike dewine has shown up at the
courthouse we're told
then attorney general mike dewine now
the governor and he
is meeting with the family he developed
a close relationship
with the rodent and gilly families as
this investigation
unfolded so one family seeking to kill
entire membership of the other family
that's that's the claim and jake wagner
apparently
has turned state's evidence and told the
investigators and the prosecutors what
happened that night and he implicated
his three other family members and i
want to tell you i've had conversations
with jake wagner's mother angela over
facebook
this was many years ago when this first
happened and she denied
any involvement whatsoever and said that
her family was being slandered
so it's very interesting now that jake
whose daughter was
apparently the subject of this custody
battle the families were involved in
has now turned state's evidence against
his entire family
so it'll be very interesting to see what
happens with the other cases and whether
or not these other families
now decide to plead guilty since the
death penalty is off the table
all right internet antoinette levy still
on the story thanks so much
when we come back the florida school
superintendent now facing charges of
perjury
in that deadly high school shooting and
we'll find out
when to expect the accused shooter
nicholas cruz to stand trial
after the break
welcome back the accused boulder store
shooter is now facing
43 new charges ahmad alissa is accused
of killing 10 people
and attempting to kill a police officer
the boulder county district attorney
announced the filing of dozens of
additional charges including
32 counts of attempted murder one count
of assault
and 10 counts of unlawful possession of
a firearm
police say alissa opened fire inside a
king supers market on march
22nd he's due back in court for a status
conference
next month and now turning to florida
the broward county school superintendent
has been
charged with perjury robert runsey is
accused of lying to a grand jury about
the use of money
that was supposed to be supporting
campus safety in the months before
the marjory stoneman high school
shooting as for the accused shooter
nicholas cruz long awaited trial
it's about to be scheduled cruz is
accused of killing
17 students and staff members on
valentine's day in 2018.
the trial was delayed due to the covet
19 pandemic however with restrictions in
florida now being lifted
the judge says she expects the trial to
begin this september
with the um the status of the trial
starting in september we have five
months so
at the pace that you all were are
working i know you're all working very
hard that
that it gives plenty of time to
accomplish everything we need and if it
doesn't we'll address it at that time
but i want you all to look
towards september as our goal as far as
starting jury selection and
pre-trial motions the crew's defense
team
says it's had difficulty connecting with
its client
his lawyers say they can now properly
prepare for the trial
for the last year we have not been able
to have any confidential
meaningful attorney-client
communications with mr cruz
so we have not been able to do that and
we still um
don't have a date that we will be able
to do that
we have not been able to get up until
recently
are experts in to evaluate mr cruz
the broward sheriff's office has been
very accommodating and the ball is
rolling on that
and brian blackmair that case is just
one of a nationwide backlog of trials
we're going to see a lot of trials soon
aren't we this year absolutely i can
tell you myself as a practicing public
defender in brooklyn
there are a number of cases that are
backlogged for the lion's share of them
it seems to be low-level cases that
should just go away
based on the fact that we have cases
like nicholas cruz
those cases need to be tried the ones
with severe injury to individuals
the non-victimless crimes so to speak
those ones are going to be first and
foremost but of course there are so many
that there's going to be a backlog and
it's take some time to get through the
mall and terry austin based on reports
so far in the cruz case it seems the
defense may try to raise the
mental state of nicholas cruz as a
defense
i think brian that that's the only
defense they can possibly
assert here he's already played you know
guilty to
shooting he's confessed to shooting 17
students
and staff members and injuring 17 others
and so he faces the death penalty and i
think
he is being you know considered to be he
already has
autism obsessive compulsive disorder
he's already harmed himself
and i think his defense is going to be
he has all of these various disorders
that has contributed to what he did and
in fact he shouldn't face the death
penalty so i think
they will be using that as a defense for
him particularly since they have the
confession there's
very little else they can do here the
question is whether or not that will be
enough
you know they tried i think to use his
confession and
exchange that for a life sentence
that did not work so i think they're
going to try very hard
to use this and to persuade the jury
ultimately that he should not face the
death penalty
because he's had lifelong issues and
he's been facing this
and hopefully that will spare his life
and i think that's the only thing they
can argue at this point unless something
else comes up
that we don't know about and brian
buchmar just quickly we're seeing so
many young people about to go on trial
for
horrible murders
absolutely we're gonna see this trial
play out for
like you said uh horrible murders and
it's
i agree with wholeheartedly with what
terry is saying about the defense here i
don't think there's so much of a defense
when it comes to the alleged crimes i
think there's maybe a defense
to try to save his life and that's the
only focus here to try to beat that
death penalty charge all right well
brian and terry thank you so much and
thanks for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
you